hello everyone welcome back to Modern
Agri machines today we are going to
explore a modern farming model that is
becoming increasingly popular and highly
effective growing melons and grained H
houses not only does this model bring
High productivity but it also protects
crops from external environmental
factors and optimizes growing
conditions let's Dive Right In
[Music]
growing melons in green houses has
several major advantages compared to
open field cultivation firstly green
houses protect plants from extreme
weather conditions like heavy rain
scorching heat or Frost ensuring
consistent quality and yield throughout
the year independent of weather
conditions furthermore the greenhouse
environment is closely controlled
temperature humidity and irrigation are
optimized for the plant's growth as a
result melons grown in green houses are
often of higher quality with evenly
ripened sweeter fruits this model also
minimizes the intrusion of pests in
diseases reducing the need for
pesticides green houses allow for
efficient water use with automatic drip
irrigation systems that conserve natural
resources
[Music]
to get started we first need to
construct a greenhouse the design and
installation must ensure durability and
protection for the plants green houses
are typically built with sturdy steel
frames and covered with UV resistant
polyethylene film allowing the plants to
absorb sunlight without damage
ventilation and temperature control
systems are also installed to maintain
ideal growing conditions for the melons
[Music]
once the greenhouse is ready the next
step is preparing the soil and planting
seeds the soil in the greenhouse must be
loosened and enriched with nutrients
Farmers plant the melon seeds in rows or
pots space 30 50 c apart giving each
plant room to thrive irrigation is done
through a drip system ensuring each
plant receives the right amount of water
and nutrients without was additionally
LED Lighting systems can be installed to
supplement sunlight especially during
cloudy
[Music]
days pollination for cucumber plants is
a crucial step in their growth process
ensuring fruit formation cucumber plants
have both male and female flowers and
for fruit to developed pollen from the
male flour must be transferred to the
female flour typically this process is
carried carried out by pollinating
insects such as bees as bees fly from
flower to flower they carry pollen from
male flowers to female flowers in
Greenhouse farming Farmers often use
manual pollination methods using small
brushes to transfer the pollen or they
raise honeybees within the greenhouse to
ensure efficient pollination this helps
the cucumber plants produce even fruits
and Achieve high yields
[Music]
[Applause]
during the growing process Farmers
regularly check the plants prune leaves
and side branches to focus nutrients on
the fruits organic or biofertilizers are
applied to provide necessary nutrition
ensuring the melons grow evenly and
sweetly thanks to the enclosed
environment of the greenhouse Pest
Control becomes easier if any signs of
pest or disease appear farmers can take
quick action without needing excessive
pesticide use
[Music]
[Applause]
after about 75 90 days the melons are
ready to be harvested Farmers carefully
inspect the fruits and choose those that
have reached perfect ripeness with
bright yellow skin the melons are hand
harvested ensuring minimal damage of the
plants and fruits
[Music]
after harvesting cucumbers undergo a
sorting process to ensure quality they
are care carefully inspected for siis
color and shape and any substandard
fruits are removed the cucumbers are
then carefully packed into boxes or bags
to protect them during Transportation
these packages usually have ventilation
holes to keep the cucumbers fresh for a
longer period once packed the cucumbers
are transported to markets supermarkets
and Distributors for
[Music]
sale the greenhouse melon growing model
has brought significant economic and
environmental benefits not only does it
increase productivity and product
quality but it also protects crops from
weather fluctuations and pests in the
future with the advancement of
Technology growing melons and
greenhouses promises to go even further
becoming a sustainable and efficient
agricultural solution for Farmers thank
you for watching today's video don't
forget to like share and subscribe to
stay updated on exciting content about
modern agricultural technology see you
in the next video on Modern Agri
machines
[Music]
oh
la
[Music]